[Music]
so she pronounces it Jaya the Sanskrit
and North Indian pronunciation is Jaya
right yeah we got by Jaya with our
daughter nice and we've got a friend
who's got a child named Jaya as well oh
cool so it seems to be in the in the air
and my name is Sanjay which means a
whiff victory oh I didn't know that the
same route Jay Jaya
oh that's cool in Sanskrit my name is
Sanjaya uh-huh and Jaya that the loose
translation of Jaya is is victory yeah
Jaya is a Sanskrit word for victory
right so where where are your parents
from my dad's from Gujarat which is on
the border of Pakistan West northwestern
India mom is from Madras got a
southeastern tip of India and when did
they immigrate they met each other in
their first jobs in Nigeria which is
where I was born
oh you were born in Nigeria in a while
and then they moved to Colorado pretty
quickly to teach my dad had gone to the
school at Conda School in the States
mm-hmm and worked for the Rockefeller
Foundation in Africa collecting
indigenous seeds so that's where the
human rights genetic material kicks in
for you I think so I ran away from it
for as long as I could
yeah and the funny thing is like my dad
was a geneticist and after kicking and
screaming I ended up working with him on
like a tomato genetics company uh-huh
you like all the tomatoes that you get
at Whole Foods the ones that are in the
clam shells from Baja are all his right
well so I kicked and screamed every way
possible and wasn't wrote back and like
the most brutally harsh way yeah
what do you mean brutally harsh I I
wouldn't if somebody had told me that I
would be following in my father's
footsteps when I was like 18 or 17
because everything inside of you was to
do something different did to like I
forged my own path uh-huh and it's like
you know we followed the foot we
followed up footsteps of those who walk
before us right as much as you know we
don't think we do of course man
so you grew up in Colorado then Colorado
and California Oakland and then we went
to Cal and
met a student of Sri Chinmoy at Cal and
as soon as I graduated I wanted to get
as far away from like academic rigor and
like materialism as possible moved to
New York where Sri Chinmoy was based but
you know I was at 400 or 500 dollars per
month mm-hmm in terms of my own budget
but the original impetus to move to New
York City was really to be a devotee of
sri shen more yeah that's exactly it
Wow what did your parents think of that
they freaked out did they say about that
PhD they're like you're supposed to be a
professor and all my relatives are like
why are you in America if you want to
follow a girl to follow Indian girls
instead you go to Queens
I go to Jamaica Queens and for people
for if I don't know if you've been to
Queens but or been to Jamaica other than
like on your way to JFK but it's like
bottom-of-the-barrel in New York City
mm-hmm so uh it's very diverse
yeah and treated moist thing was like
don't hide from the world and so like
most gurus like live in kawaii Malibu
haha right he's in Queens in Queens so
like you know I learned fast it's a trip
I mean what was it about Sri Chinmoy
that connected with you why did you feel
this pole in high school I was in a
really conservative community a suburb
of Oakland a weirdly conservative
community in my senior year friends of
mine started getting into just it to
kind of rebel into the Dalai Lama and
like you know Jonathan Livingston
Seagull and those types of books and
when I went to college it was Berkeley I
could you can't you can no you can't
avoid it and so started meditating and
started trying to find a spiritual path
in most places I went what was what was
the driver behind that though you know
because my parents were so academically
minded they had made me do everything I
did like from sports to music - like
overachieving it was I did exactly what
they wanted and when I got to school I
realized I was still doing exactly what
they wanted and I needed to find my own
way you're being a good Indian song I
was the oldest you have siblings I don't
know if I was being
the average Indians ha ha yeah just
doing what you were expected to do yeah
and so you you what you had you
experienced some kind of void and trying
to figure out what it was that made you
you I realize like I was so deep on a
path that wasn't of my own choosing and
I needed to find a way to choose my own
path and I realized quickly that
couldn't be through academics like I had
to go on an inner search and you know
the writings of sri ramakrishna really
really inspired me mm-hmm
and that's when I realized like I've got
professors you know like why can't I
have like a teacher for what I want to
do in terms of self-realization right
well that's that's also going back to
your Indian heritage it is but it was
almost like osmosis because my parents
generation moved to the u.s. to get away
from that it was the first time that
Indians in the modern era could like you
know have material aspirations and so
they were all about the material life
now they're not but they were then
uh-huh and they're trying to acclimate
you to become American so to speak a big
time it was like Kraft macaroni and
cheese and hamburgers right you know
like now I love curry like oh I can't
believe like I didn't eat any of that
stuff when I was growing up and so when
you start meditating and going on this
path and and yeah your parents must have
been well I would imagine it must be
somewhat mixed like on the one hand like
okay he's verging from this trajectory
that we've sort of established for him
but at the same time there's something
you know beautiful about you connecting
with what you know could be
characterized as you know you're sort of
inherent Native traditions it's true the
one thing that everybody has a difficult
time with especially in the West is how
much obedience you need to follow a
teacher whether the teachers a Zen
practitioner or whether the teacher is
is your martial arts teacher or whether
it's an Indian guru and so like I
literally put myself at the feet of Sri
Chinmoy
and I asked him you know my parents
really want me to go to grad school and
want me to be a doctor you know from an
inner standpoint you know what's your
belief answer each in my meditate
and said in an almost otherworldly tone
your soul does not want you to be a
doctor your soul wants you to strengthen
your heart and so first thing I did is I
went to my parents it was like a stretch
in my what I what I should do and he
said your soul doesn't want you to be a
doctor and they're like what what is
that even mean like no you know like you
are becoming a doctor and then Sri
Chinmoy told me cryptically you know
that I still had to please my parents so
it's like it was almost like a Cohen
like right
don't please your parents don't please
your parents and what does strengthen
your heart actually mean I had a hard
time understanding that because I think
as as as men or boys in this country
we're not really in at least when I grew
up in the 80s and 90s we weren't really
encouraged to find those qualities of
the heart like love and sympathy and
generosity and you know academic life
obviously strengthens your mind much
more than your heart and I realize like
I needed to develop qualities of love of
sympathy of joy not for anybody else but
for myself and that would actually give
me the strength to like be confident
with my convictions and what was the
process of exploring that for you it was
totally detaching myself from that
Western tract I mean I went from like
4.0 at Cal to working at a community
health food store in Queens at 100
dollars per week living in a house with
15 other dudes uh-huh and going out
devotees they all were and we all had
our own little rooms you know rent was
$200 per month and you know going to
morning and evening meditations and that
was it that was that was it and a lot of
service like we gave a lot of free
meditation classes and there were like
athletic races that weirdly enough you
know this Indian teacher really wanted
us to participate in and I traveled with
them and I did that pretty much non-stop
until a point when he said you know he
didn't say this explicitly but he was
like you know you're ready to do more
and that's when he kind of pushed me
into the sphere of human rights mm-hmm
we were chatting
the other week when we when we first met
and I was sharing with you that my only
real awareness of Sri Chinmoy was when I
was living in New York City right after
college and I would see people running
you know in Central Park or all over the
city
wearing Sri Chinmoy t-shirts and I was
like who is this Sri Chinmoy is he like
a coach to a running club but there
seemed to be this almost cultish
conglomeration of people everywhere I
looked who were running all over
Manhattan wearing paraphernalia that was
advertising Sri Chinmoy and I thought he
must be some kind of cult guru or
something like that and I didn't really
explore it any further than that at that
point but I've since come to learn and
what your film which we're going to talk
about in a minute so beautiful he
explores is like who this man who this
man was what he stood for and and the
impact that he's had not just on you
spiritually but on you know a vast
community of people and how that sort of
intertwines very beautifully and
naturally with the running community in
New York City you know it's it's hard to
believe that marathon running at one
point in the 60s and even mid 70s was
absolutely counterculture I mean if you
read the early New York City marathons
what you were just you know five or six
laps around Central Park the people that
did those were thought to be crazy and
when Fred Lebow decided to do the 1976
you know big five boroughs marathon in
honor of the Bicentennial I think that's
the first time that marathoning kind of
reached the mainstream and Sri Chinmoy
was in New York at that point and you
know was very very supportive of this
flourishing of people's aspirations to
try to do something that was seemingly
impossible I mean now like from year
five ultra standout the 50 ultras and 50
days that bar has been pushed right but
in 1976 1977 like 26.2 miles was like
the edge of the envelope and you know
it's New York City in the 70s so before
the 1977 and 1978 New York City
marathons the day before Fred Lee bone
the New York City Road runners would
have Sri Chinmoy lead
tations he had an indian grew in a dhoti
in Central Park with runners meditating
it's crazy
yeah and just just to kind of provide a
little exposition on this I mean for
those that don't know Fred Lebow is a
legendary character who really can be
credited with contributing to the
explosion of interest and distance
running by virtue of the work that he
did with a was he the president of the
New York Road Runners Club he was he
really did he want he founded it - I
actually Ted Corbett oh I don't know
about Ted Corvette Ted Corbett
african-american 1952 Olympic marathoner
for the US and Helsinki Ted is known as
the Motta's as the father of modern
ultramarathon just by accident he lived
in the Bronx and his training weeks were
sometimes 200 300 miles low in New York
City because he would even fifties in
the 50s and 60s he would leave his home
at 7 or 8 in the morning and he would
run and he would come back and he'd do
these you know 12 14 hour runs every
Saturday and Sunday
just for fun and Fred was the founder I
mean Ted was the founder of the New York
Road Runners Club and Fred ended up
launching it into what it is today
right so Fred pioneers this craze of
marathoning and I you know I remember as
a 10 11 year-old 12 whatever there was
this period of time in which marathon
and running kind of exploded into
mainstream awareness and you had guys
like Jim Fixx who were writing books
about it and people were discovering
this for the very first time and and
Manhattan and specifically the New York
Road rowing club and the work that Fred
was doing was kind of the that was like
the mecca for everything that was
occurring at that time it really was and
and I think Fred's imagination was
unbounded he had heard that in the late
1800s there was this phenomenon of
pedestrianism six-day races held in
Madison Square Garden where people bet
on the the man or woman who would do the
most miles in six days and fed wanted to
revive that in the 80s so with the help
of Sri Chinmoy and his marathon team
they started a six-day race in Flushing
Meadow Park and
that brought out the people that had the
feeling and that knew that they had the
capacity for more than 26 miles like the
great Stu Mittleman and all these
characters that wanted to go well beyond
the 26 mile limit and well beyond the
hundred or 200 mile limit so these races
in Madison Square Garden like when was
that going on they were hugely popular
late 1800s to really nineteen times
extraordinarily popular and if you look
back even before the first Olympics in
19 in 1896 people were doing like cross
UK walks you know these epic walks in in
in the United States too and they were
races where people would race almost
Tour de France style trying to get from
point A to point B in the fastest time
taking help from villagers or town folks
etc that's like lost history though
because I've never read anything about
that and it's the foundation of what was
known as multi-day running I mean these
days ultra running is more is more
popular than ever and the multi-day ID
has kind of been lost but you know in
the 80s and 90s it seemed much easier to
do larger events around half mile or
one-mile loops whether the situation was
controlled of course now like you know
but the Leadville and hardrock hundred
and western states the idea of mountain
running and point-to-point hundreds have
really really exploded but it's it's
it's so fascinating that you know in the
70s when when marathoning really came of
age that was considered like the
ultimate distance that a human being
could run and it completely belies the
the true history of these crazy races
that preceded it which get no ink and
sadly the marathon was considered to be
the greatest distance a man could run it
wasn't until the 1984 Olympics that
there was a 10k for the woman hour a
marathon for the women when did it was
84 the first time there was a women's
marathon yeah in 1980 in the in the
Russian Olympics there was an exhibition
10k and it wasn't until 84 where a woman
had been running professionally for 8 to
10 years of course there have been women
that it's a Katherine Schweitzer that
sneaked into the Boston Marathon you
know 15 years or so before 12 years
before the 1984 Olympics
but it wasn't until I think the in my
opinion until the multi-day race
circuits happened that people realized
that the capacity the difference between
men and women really wasn't that great
you know there's longer it gets the the
narrower the cop is it's true there's
almost no running distance under
actually there are no running distances
under 26 miles where the top 10 men you
know where the top woman is in the top
10 men but when you got to 24 hours and
48 and 72 and then six-day races you
know it wasn't unusual for a woman to
actually win the entire event and now
you have people like Cortney doe Walter
who's just crushing the dudes it's in
these super long races it's unreal you
know and and that goes to the heart of I
think why Sri Chinmoy
was really into these races it's a
concept of self transcendence you know
going beyond what people tell you your
limitations are what you think your
limitations are digging deep into your
heart and trying to pull out an energy
that transcends male or female and for a
little bit more exposition it's it's
it's worth kind of exploring the history
of Sri Chinmoy because for him running
wasn't something that was tagged on top
of his spiritual perspective like he
himself was a champion runner he ran 100
meters ran his whole life was running
races essentially up until you know the
day he died and and running very much as
a part of his perspective when it comes
to this idea of self transcendence he
grew up in an ashram in South India that
was run by Sri Aurobindo
surrender was one of the original
revolutionaries in India and he had a
spiritual revelation and you know
basically renounced his revolutionary
ways and moved to then French India
which was Pondicherry to escape the
British and started an ashram and a lot
of the revolutionaries that followed his
in his essence like semi terroristic
ways you know ended up renouncing
themselves and moving to follow the
spiritual life but after India's
independence a lot of Europeans came to
the ashram and you know brought this
dynamism into Indian spirituality which
had been absent
a few hundred years answer er Binda
really encouraged
track-and-field he really encouraged the
development of the physical body to be a
true vessel of the spiritual energies
that people were aspiring to and so Sri
Chinmoy was a disciple he was a disciple
though and he competed in the hundred
meter dash and the decathlon there and
then when he moved to America in 1964 I
think there was a gap of six or seven
years where he was so focused on being a
spiritual teacher and serving people's
needs spiritually that the athletic side
was absent I don't think it was until
the early 70s when running really began
to to revitalize especially
long-distance that he saw the corollary
between long-distance running and
spirituality and the metaphor of us
running towards a spiritual goal and
using outer running as as a way to
practice that - right so he starts as a
sprinter later realizes the the
potential of long-distance running to
serve a spiritual and or goal or pursuit
or journey and he moves to the United
States I mean this is also an
interesting period of time where there's
a there's sort of a group of spiritual
leaders who are arriving in the United
States from India you have Krishnamurti
Yogananda who comes much earlier and
what so what is the you know what was
the rationale behind him leaving India
to come to the United States the way Sri
Chinmoy tells that is that he would have
been content to stay in India and
meditate you know 12 to 18 hours a day
as he'd been doing but he hadn't
experienced like a lot of these teachers
did of the Supreme of the Divine you
know basically instructing him that his
destiny lay in the West to be of service
to sincere seekers so he just got on a
plane like no real visa other than a
tourist visa there are students have CR
been those that lived in New York that
were her sponsors but he just came based
on his own inner obedience and it was
Greenwich Village in 1964 and you know
it was pretty quick that he began to
address
kind of ideas that he's talking about
right
and so by 1970 he began leading
twice-a-week meditations at the UN and
there was a rapid rapid acceptance of
his philosophy because it dovetailed so
much with I think what Western seekers
were looking for but at the same time he
didn't require a complete out of
renunciation like nobody wore robes and
nobody had to move into caves right so
you're not walking around like a hearty
Krishna no not necessarily hopefully
we're all we all have the same spirit
within but you know he didn't he didn't
pay much attention to the same type of
outer signs or outer decorum that Indian
spirituality traditionally required like
the robes and you know the the the
markings and the beads and things like
that and did he I assume he must have
run the New York Marathon himself many
times he did he ran the New York City
Marathon a few times but then you know
he started a forty seven mile race in
honor of his 47th birthday which I
believe was in 1978 and that was the
first time his students began running
ultras and he enjoyed it and then he
began pushing that in doing 100-mile
races 200 mile races and when Fred Lebow
came to him in the mid-80s and said
let's do a six-day race I mean Sri
Chinmoy and what became his marathon
team was ready mm-hmm and so where does
the 3100 come into play like how is that
birthed you know I think spiritual
teachers develop vessels for
consciousness in the sense that I think
if he tried to start obviously if you
tried to start a 3,000 100 mile race in
1976 when the marathon I loved it you
know
you battled out but it wouldn't like
somebody would have checked him into
some type of facility but after the
six-day race it became a ten day race
after the ten day race it became a seven
hundred thousand and thirteen hundred
mile race and people were doing really
really well at that and by 1996 he
decided to almost double the 1300 and
make it 2700 and people did it you know
there was a one woman and three men that
did it
and then in 1997 he said okay this is
the distance I'm not gonna go beyond it
it's 30 100 right 3100 miles this race
has taken place every year since 90 what
is it 1997 97 and this is a race that
entails running 30 100 miles within a
period of 50 52 52 days which means each
runner is gonna have to complete on
average about 60 miles a day the kicker
is the course is essentially a half mile
loop around high school in Queens on
sidewalk in the summer yeah it's
ridiculous
it is absolutely insane and I'd heard
whispers of this race over the years and
I think I just filed it away in my brain
as apocryphal like I thought well this
can't actually be occurring in New York
City because you don't really hear about
it
it doesn't get any press and what was so
amazing about seeing it in your movie is
that this occurs without really any
fanfare whatsoever
there's how many there were 12 people
that that did it and that that were
documented what was it last year that
that you followed these individuals yeah
2016 there were 12 participants and they
just spend their summer running around
in a circle they alternate the direction
every other day or something like that
there's a couple buses and campers
parked out on the sidewalk and you know
some volunteers there to hand out food
and and write down there how many laps
they've done every day the course is
open from 6:00 a.m. to midnight and it
just goes on until it's done and when
it's finished they're like okay you did
it and then it's essentially that's it
it's mind boggling you know I lived in
that area since 1997 and I've frankly
was frightened of that race I'd run by
it it's unlike my one-mile point on my
mind wouldn't even talk about the fact
that you're a runner like you came from
a competitive running background but
that distance just frightened every
single pore of my body you know I didn't
understand how
or why anybody would want to do that and
after you know I guess a career in human
rights and when I started getting into
film I started wondering why a film
hadn't been made on that race of course
it would be the most boring film in the
world if any film was just about people
going in circles
but I was encouraged to do a six-day
race you know to try to feel what people
might possibly get out of a 30 100 miles
that when you were kind of contemplating
the idea of trying to find a way in and
make a movie about this this event you
know it was even more Elementary than
that I
I need before trying to make a movie I
needed to understand like why to make a
movie you know what could possibly
appeal to a non 30 100 mile run er about
this race like why would anybody want to
do might want to watch a movie about
something that's so beyond what we might
even want to consider doing and so I did
a six-day race on the same course that
Fred Lebow had started in 1986 and I
didn't really train much the interesting
thing about ultras is that you know you
see people from 18 to 70 years old doing
ultras and particularly since a lot of
older people do ultras I went in without
much training thinking like if a 70 year
old could do it like why couldn't I you
know I did about 50 miles the first six
hours then I got injured it's like I
felt my hamstring 20 to 50 miles in 6
hours that's pretty good you know I
think I didn't know what to do I didn't
know I didn't know how to approach it
but then I felt my hamstring twinge and
as it twinged a few 75 year old ladies
walked by me and asked me how I was
doing and that's what I realized I can't
cook it you know it's like if these
women are doing this race and also the
nature of how you approach and conquer
an event like that is very different
than the mindset you know of the typical
runner or whatever your background in
and running experience was and so that
the next four days actually the next
four and a half days I was out on the
course 18 hours and I was barely doing
32 miles
I had a pulled hamstring mm-hmm and all
I could do in those four and a half days
was pray pray that I would get to run
again in the race you know I was never
more conscious of like my my frailty
then having 75 year old men and women
chatting with you and then apologizing
saying you're slowing me down and then
moving beyond but I would say almost
miraculously and without hyperbole what
the day left my hamstrings felt normal
that just in an instant felt it felt
normal and then I took off it's like I
channeled I'd held like five almost five
full days of Prayer in my heart and when
that prayer had been answered I took off
and for the next about twenty-one hours
I was honestly in the highest meditation
I've ever been in and you know it's like
we all say that like people sometimes
they like it when I chop onions it's
meditative and I don't mean like
repetitive I don't mean that my mind was
turned off I mean that every single
spiritual pore of my being felt like it
was about to have the biggest awakening
my imagination felt like reality you
know I was like feeling Hanuman I was
feeling like every Indian mythological
story I'd ever read I was feeling the
presence of those beings on that course
and no matter what I did whether I
stopped to eat I stopped to fix my shoes
as soon as I start running again those
experiences came to the fore you were
having a transcendent experience I was
so what do you make of that you know
when I talked to runners after that who
did the 3100 they said this is why we do
it and I said does it does that
experience happen in minute one they
said no but after four or five or six
days regardless of injuries like I had
in the six-day race after four or five
or six days they find that their mind
shuts off finally surrenders to the
inevitable fact that they would have to
be running for the next you know 52 days
and the heart comes to the fore in some
cases the soul comes to the fore and
they get experiences that are extremely
challenging to get through silent
meditation
mm-hmm yeah you hear stories from people
who are who are quite expert in
meditation that it takes a very long
time perhaps years to of consistent
diligent practice to get to a place
where you can have that kind of
experience but once you have it you
develop the acuity to drop into it a
little bit with with more facility right
and I would imagine for some of these
runners maybe they they can if they're
experienced in this sort of thing they
can drop into that state perhaps sooner
without having it to be you know on on
day six of the six day run so do you
think you have to reach a certain level
of suffering and pain to arrive at that
place or what is the what's the trigger
I thought I did I thought that I thought
that was the trigger after the Six Day
race I realized that there was a movie
to be made if I could capture that
spiritual essence of ultra distance
running it you know it might it might be
of some service I wanted to explore
traditional practices of running and of
course people who've read Born to Run
know about the Roar Amaury the taro mara
Indians that are connected culturally to
the Indians in the southwest of the
United States so I went to Santa Fe to
meet a friend who ran an organization
called the wings of America which really
focuses on Native American running
culture and revitalizing that I met one
of the board members who is an ultra
distance runner on the Navajo Nation and
when I went on a morning run with him I
realized that his attitude towards
running was totally different than mine
I started my watch you know it's looking
for the GPS signal is like this is gonna
be a great Strava run through the canyon
and it was a canyon that people who
weren't natives weren't allowed to run
in but we had permission to run in it it
sounds like I'm gonna get some course
records all this stupid stuff that like
you know technology and my competition
you know kind of you know for me to
believe but he was running for different
reasons the Navajo run towards the east
in the morning because that's where the
Rising Sun is
and I could tell that this fellow Shawn
Martin who's a athletic director in
Chile High School in Arizona
he was receptive to the idea that this
run this regular morning run would make
him a better person it could also give
him an exceptionally spiritual
experience and that was his attitude for
running and that had been baked in
through 32 years of cultural training on
how to run and so that's when I realized
like most spiritual teachers say like
suffering isn't the only path to
enlightenment and I think it's the same
in running it's like suffering isn't the
only path to the ultimate running
experience Carl Lewis used to say the
same thing he used to be so against that
the the idiom no pain no gain
you know there's different attitude to
approach sports and I saw it in Sean
Martin that day through the movie you
explore the culture of the Navajo Nation
you travel to Japan and spend time with
the running monks of mount GI is that
how you say it
yeah yeah I write I would say that you
pronounce it as perfectly good right
which is fascinating and I want to dive
into that more in a minute and then also
the the Botswana and try to the the
Kalahari right and there the culture of
kind of persistent hunting and and how
running plays into that and in your
you're kind of learning process your
discovery process of trying to
understand these cultures and how
running and spirituality form
essentially who they are like what is it
that you have discovered about this
relationship between spirituality
transcendence running and and and and
really you know the title of your movie
which is running to become like what
does that mean you know to practice at
all
colonization has been a really bad thing
for running cultures you know from the
British colonization of India
you the black Botswana government's
colonization of the Kalahari to Anglo
European colonization of the United
States there haven't been many cultures
that have been able to keep this
connection to running in the past 500 or
600 years or maybe in the past 10,000
since we've been agrarian societies but
in the last few hundred the remaining
running cultures have been forcibly
separated from that tradition and first
and foremost that's been really sad to
see and it's it's not just you know
white Western Europeans again the
Botswana government is black African and
the Chinese for example destroyed a
culture in Tibet of long gone pot
running which we tried to explore and
this almost sounds like like woowoo but
people were sequestered into caves for
two or three years at a time and they
sat in lotus position and using the
prana they would gradually try to burst
upwards and at the end of two or three
years they were able to in lotus
position burst up three feet and that
gave them the kind of pranic that the
metaphysical approach to a different
style of running there was a German
priest and a German nun in the 30s and
50s respectively who witnessed runners
running across boulder fields in tibet
going at what they estimated was you
know equivalent of now six-minute per
mile pace what these runners would
fixate on a star at 8 p.m. and run
towards it till 6:00 or 7:00 in the
morning and that's a 12-hour run where
they're going six-minute pace through
this long gone pot running Wow and when
the Chinese took over Tibet they didn't
destroy the monastery but they killed
all the monks in that monastery so as we
explored these ancestral traditions of
running we found that there were very
very few Native American running culture
was extent until really about 150 years
ago now they didn't have horses you know
in a modern sense until about 1680 1700
before that they relied on runners to
run 100 200 300 mile
you know trading and spiritual routes so
that was you know it kind of an
exhilarating discovery especially when
we saw that alive and well in Botswana
hmm well the sort of most well-known of
these cultures is probably the
Tarahumara in Mexico and and I would
imagine that a big reason why it serves
as such a test case a case study is
because the Copper Canyon has done such
an amazing job of protecting them from
the outside world preventing that kind
of pollution that's occurred that's sort
of undermined these other these other
tribes and has sort of allowed them to
continue their their ancestral habits
which prioritize running as essentially
a lifestyle I don't know what the
spiritual connection is with the
Tarahumara but I did have one experience
where I ran with one when I was in
Mexico City
and it was amazing it was a it was an
event that was sponsored by runner's
world and it was on a track in Mexico
City and it was like kind of a Expo type
situation so I had the opportunity to
run around a track with this guy and
he's in his traditional garb with the
sandals and like the whole thing and I
almost felt it was almost like he was
efficient in an aquarium you know I was
like I wasn't even sure that he really
understood what was happening like he'd
been flown out there almost put on
display but I could tell in running with
him it was so natural it was so pure
like you said there's no none of the
trappings of our modern culture of
running there's no GPS watch or anything
like that and his gait was so effortless
and beautiful and you could tell that
this is just an extension of a lineage
lineage that goes back you know many
many many generations I mean that's the
great thing about running you know my
colonization rent aside running unites
us you know at one point every single
culture on earth relied on running again
we weren't agricultural no one was
agricultural until 10,000 years ago
which meant that we were all hunters and
gatherers and the fastest stronger
strongest runners were the ones that
were more
adept at hunting so it's literally baked
into our DNA and it's baked into our
culture if we can rediscover that mm-hmm
so when someone says to you we were born
to run like what does that mean to you
you know I the book was really really
inspiring but I think there was there
were some parts of the book that might
have been misunderstood there's a
fascination with these traditional
ancestral called an ancient running
cultures like the Terra mara like the
Navajo like the Hopi like the Bushmen
that they have some deep genetic
advantage that they're super human or
theirs they have special DNA or that
it's their food they're chia seeds that
make them like the Panola yeah that make
them better runners but they're better
runners because they work harder than at
it and they feel it's more important I
mean for someone who wants to run to
lose weight a run to win a race those
are really you know strong and powerful
motivations but if you feel that running
is a form of Prayer you have a different
attitude and our Navajo character who
actually is the race director of the
Tara Mars Copper Canyon race he told me
he said running is a prayer you know
when you're running your feet are
praying to mother earth you're breathing
in father sky running is a celebration
of life it's like when you run you
appreciate everything around you and
running as a teacher you know teaches
you about who you are it helps you to
get through hardships my high school
running coach never said anything like
that to me you might have gotten fired
if he did yeah it was like a run to win
and that was it and if you were a second
even if you PR that was just like that's
three point that's better five points
yeah it's super interesting I heard you
tell a story about one of the
participants in in the most recent
iteration of the thirty one hundred who
I think was a semi-pro runner from
Israel Camille's real right right who
kind of
showed up guns blazing laid down a
torrid pace for the first thousand miles
or whatever it was and then had a little
bit of a reckoning that led to an
epiphany that kind of speaks to what you
just said Koby oren and i was in one
race with him and in that race he wasn't
ultimately successful but he was trying
to break a tenday record of 901 miles
like that's the level that he's on he
was you know he's on pace to do 90 miles
a day in that race until the last couple
of days so he's insane he's a really
good runner and like all Israeli
citizens he has a military background so
he came in to the 3100 race this last
summer 2018 with a plan
it was just like operation control
everything
tactical that you could need you know he
had it and in the first thousand miles
of his 30 100-mile race that thousand
mile split set an Israeli national
record for a thousand miles and he was
racing he was racing this fellow from
Russia named Basu but then something
softened in Kobe and not softened in a
weak way
Kobe later recounted that there was a
point in the race when he realized that
he could race he could race the race and
you know he could be just pushing his
physical limits but he would have missed
the point entirely
and he felt that if he'd done that maybe
he would have won the race but he
wouldn't have remembered anything
significant about him he had the
Epiphany that that thirty one hundred
mile race wasn't a journey from point A
to point B or zero miles to 3100 miles
he said the race is a pilgrimage and
that separated himself from even the
kind of like micro focus of like lap by
lap by lap when you're on a pilgrimage
everything that you do is a ritual and
he realized that each one of his steps
was a ritual his motions his attitude
were rituals and that reminded me
explicitly of the marathon monks of
Monte I the running monks a Mountie I
you know they choose one aspirant every
seven years to do a thousand days of
running split up into ten hundred day
chunks each hundred day cycle we'll have
a set mileage the first one is 11 miles
a day
the last one is 56 miles a day and all
of their cycles occur on a mountain
that's about 3,000 feet in net elevation
so they're going up and down the
mountain at least once towards the end
they're going up and down two or three
times and they're so precise in their
footsteps that every single day every
single step is in the exact same place I
mean that's next level it's like wow
that's how much they're just focusing on
the moments so Japanese it's so Japanese
you know but I love that idea of running
as ritual you know and and and and I
think it was somebody in the movie said
you know I'm just trying to be the best
person that I can be with each stride
right this ritualization running as
ritual as prayer as this act of of you
know as this act on the journey toward
self transcendence and and I think that
the example of these running monks is
the most powerful and demonstrative I
mean a thousand days of doing this 10
100 day cycles and the penalty for
failure is suicide right you just say
that again the penalty for failure on
this quest to literally for a thousand
days go out and do anywhere between like
11 miles and fifty something miles right
if they fail suicide is the penalty and
correct me if I'm wrong but there's they
select one person at a time to attempt
this correct and their selection process
has become so rigorous that in the last
hundred fifty years of this now 1500
year tradition no one has had to take
their own life but plenty have and they
said and this is the interesting thing
they said that when they start this
quest no one is thinking of suicide it's
like they're thinking of bliss
they feel that because the penalty is so
great they've been able to keep this
practice absolutely uncompromised for
the last 2015 hundred years it's been
going on that long yeah that's the
interesting thing to me it's like the
stakes are so high that the only people
that are gonna do it are ones who are
going to basically establish the deepest
commitment to that goal where they're
willing to sacrifice their life yeah and
you have to be so dialed in mentally
emotionally and spiritually to come from
a place of joy and gratitude and bliss
rather than fear I mean the American the
Western perspective on that would be to
just be terrified the entire time I mean
it's absolutely insane the the
ridiculous thing to I mean from a
Western standpoint is that there's no
aid there's no aid stations there's no
helpers the aspirant starts in the
morning usually without even as much as
a cup of miso soup just some liquid and
after about two-thirds of the way
through sometimes thirty miles has an
aide stop take sanity and then continues
to the end and then has to make his own
meals at the end of this 56 mile day and
they're not really running though I mean
they're essentially hiking they are it's
like it's it's a very steep mountain and
the aspirants are all wearing sandals
mmm we're the Sam Botta fall costume
with this amazing hat I don't know what
you call that but it's incredible it
looks like Star Wars ya know it really
does and so they're in this garb where
you know without getting too crass I
think it would be really hard to disrobe
if you did have to go to the bathroom so
they're they're very light at the same
time you know we were up there with the
aspirant and no one had been allowed to
film up there since 1984 is that when
they made that really grainy documentary
that I saw yeah actually a lot of things
wrong in that documentary because I used
it as a research and when I presented
those facts to the monks they were like
where did you get that from mmm and I
said from this movie they're like no no
no that's like what was incorrect in the
movie
there was a lot of numbers that were
wrong daily mileage you know and and I
think that movie established them as
what the moniker of marathon monks and
like you said they don't run and they
hate even though I caught up the
marathon amongst they hated that that
label but when we were up there the
aspirant on flats is doing about 1111
1/2 minute mile pace so it's like he's
walking but you can say he's walking
with an incredible amount of purpose you
know we could we we didn't even attempt
to keep up with him we had to spend two
days to be able to kind of cover his one
circuit just because it was impossible
even in a car to get to places before he
would mm-hmm and if you were to ask
these people what is the purpose of this
what is their reply this is the
interesting thing you know in order to
get permission to do this I met the head
monk three times and this head monk had
actually done this quest he was the last
finisher everything I asked from a
Western standpoint he didn't answer in a
Western wife so when I said what is the
purpose I actually asked him that he
said I don't understand the question
hmm he said we do this because we feel
that but that we are the go-between the
intermediaries between the Buddha and
humanity and that our prayers actually
have an effect on the prayers of sincere
aspirants worldwide he basically
intimated that the purity of the request
raised the bar for every practitioner of
Buddhism whether or not they were aware
that this quest was existing mm-hmm this
is it's almost an ascetic practice of
purification that somehow penetrates
consciousness Sri Chinmoy said something
similar he said that faith is collective
that your faith is my faith is
everyone's faith and that power of faith
essentially is like a bank that we all
from different cultures draw upon and I
think that's what this marathon Montes
met this monk of Monte I intimated that
they were basically depositing large
sums through their quest into a vault
that aspirants were drawing from around
the world right I mean it's part and
parcel of the kind of core perspective
of Buddhism being that the best way to
better the world or improve the world is
to improve yourself and this is a prop
like it like the ultimate process of
purification like their version of that
you know the the interesting similarity
that I found between these monks and the
main character in the movie Ashbury
Hahnel was that they have no lethargy I
mean I can imagine what lethargy means
it means comfort it means sitting you
mean one might say that like we're in a
very comfortable position right now
sitting these monks they don't sit like
they'll sit to pray but they'll sit and
pray with intensity and that when that's
done they'll move on to the next
activity and the monk that we were
interviewing with the last aspirant to
have completed it he's physically active
from the moment he wakes up to the
moment he goes to sleep like every
minute is accounted for he's not wasting
a single second the word comfort
relaxation is not in his vocabulary at
all and the people that do the 3100 the
one similarity is that at least in that
period when they're doing those 52 days
there's not an ounce of lethargy it's
like they're looking at every moment as
though it counts yeah if they're resting
they're resting there's no cell phones
there's no music there's nothing but
they'll find that they can get enough
rest from a 10 or 15 minute nap to get
back out on the course and do 20 or 30
more miles whereas the normal human
being would extend that 10-minute rest
into a five six hours
yeah well this aspirant this Japanese
monk did you feel like you could like
connect with him I mean does he
just such a foreign creature that you
almost feel like he's a different
species like does he have a humanity to
him that you can relate to at all you
know not to to even mildly toot my own
horn but you know like my life even
though we don't dress as pronunce yet
it's it's very much an aesthetic life
like I've never married you know we're
celibate don't eat meat don't drink
don't smoke so when I went up to Mount
II I I had a daunting task you know a
lot of people I mean right I think every
week they filled media requests and they
turned down nearly all of them except
for some photography requests of people
wanting to see the monk coming or going
from from his domicile but a nun in
Kyoto made the introduction between me
and one of the head monks and you know
as a triathlete it's like when you're
with other triathletes you can speak a
certain language and as I don't know how
many triathlons or what what your
approach has been just by the language
and and the verbiage you use and you the
reference to certain races and certain
courses and so I immediately began
speaking with the head monk you know on
that purely spiritual level and it was
unusual I think for him to have a media
request from somebody that wasn't your
like prototypical right this isn't the
BBC rolling in no and my question to him
wasn't whether he would give me
permission to do what I wanted to do I
asked him I guess in a very Japanese way
if he would give me permission to do a
film that he essentially would direct
and then he was a little taken aback and
he said I've never thought of this in
this way and I said well you know if if
you were with with humility if you were
to make a film about this how would you
do it and then for the next hour and a
half he lay it out exactly how he would
do it and then at the end of that I said
I promise you I would do exactly that
and so it was that kind of like
spiritual recognition that I think got
us in the door and when I saw the monk I
understand was doing the the the quest I
understood how serious his commitment
was not that I could relate to it it was
on a on a level that I'd never
experienced but I could recognize that
he had a tremendous amount of purity a
tremendous amount of honor and a
tremendous amount of heart you know
you're in a state where you're praying
that to the divine and the Buddhist
wouldn't but this wouldn't use the word
divine that used the word light or soul
but you're praying to the highest you're
praying to the Buddha with all your
hearts devotion and you know in in the
purely Indian sense like devotions a
beautiful fluid thing that's full of
love and I recognize that in him it's
like his commitment was serious like he
did not want to be messed with
he did not want to be disturbed because
he was communicating with his beloved he
was communicating with the divine and
it's like if you weren't going to be
exactly a part of that then he had
nothing to do with you or if you had the
inability to appreciate a really
understand that that's what was
happening exactly and we couldn't have
done it without his permission so in his
offseason the winter they don't do the
quest in his offseason he consulted with
the head monk as to what we wanted to do
and what the head monk thought would be
possible and gave his explicit
permission and then made his own
requests so in essence even though we
weren't communicating with him verbally
when we were up there you know he would
recognize when we were doing something
that you know we that he had already
given approval to and there was a few
things that it was embarrassing that he
did twice because he recognized that we
didn't exactly get it the first time
there was one spot where he would sit
and he would pray and he did a second
take especially for us without us even
communicating that we needed for him to
do it a second time because he realized
you didn't quite get it or something
like that it's like imagine being the
star of a narrative film like let's do
your Brad Pitt or Angelina Jolie when
you
you you do your take and you realize
that there's a little bit of chaos I
didn't tell ya
or that the DP and the crew didn't nail
it like you did your best part and they
kind of screwed it up you could either
just go like that's it I'm not doing
this scene again or you could go like
okay I know you guys didn't really get
that right and you're not saying it so
like let me do it again
uh-huh so he was very worried that he
was a focus and we had you know like I
wouldn't say like non-spiritual crew but
we had crude that you know this was
their first experience but someone like
him and at the very end these were like
young ACS and you know assistant camera
people at the end of our shoot we hustle
to like this point in the forest where
we knew that he would stop for a minute
if devotees came to ask for his
blessings so there was a road Japanese
ladies and then there was a row of us
and like you know 20-something hipster
Brooklynites and they're like you know
jean shorts on their knees but their
hands folded and he came by and he said
prayers over us and then he looked at us
obviously knowing that we speak English
and he said thank you and for these like
assistant cameraman like these 22 23
year olds from Williamsburg like they
were blown away because after a few days
with them they recognized that he was on
a higher level than any of us and when
he recognized their work and said thank
you they just became like putty they
couldn't stop talking about it that's so
wild how long were you up there for the
shoot we had to spend two weeks on
location planning every shot the head
monk and his assistant stipulated that
everything we did was planned
effectively with the same meticulous
nature as everything they do on that
mountain
so from Wright pans to zooms to you know
cables and dollies went through it Wow
and we rehearsed it because we knew that
number one as you know from from our
movie 3101 him to come
there's no interviews there's no talking
heads at the same time like watching
running is really boring if
people passing by a camera and the
question was like how do we put people
into the spiritual mindset of this
aspirant if we don't even get to talk to
him
so our shots were planned with great
detail as you saw in the movie we shot a
lot at night that the monk carries
around at night a single Lantern with a
single candle to light the five feet in
front of him and it's mystical it's
beautiful and we didn't want to miss the
opportunities that we had yeah where do
you stay do you have to hike up the
mountain every day like you weren't
staying in the monastery were you you
know a lot of these big mountain
monasteries they have hotels but the
hotels are run run by monks and Japanese
temple cuisine is an absolute delicacy
because you can't find that in any city
in any restaurant you have to go to
these temples and people make
reservations months in advance to go and
eat effectively Japanese vegan cuisine
and dinner will be 26 to 28 items I mean
they'll be like an udon soup preparation
that's literally - slurps in a little
tiny bowl on a little clay pot lit by a
single candle and you'll have 25 26
things like that
so it's cool that reminds me of that
beautiful Korean monk chef woman who was
the subject of chef's table who's on a
monastery
I believe it's somewhere in South Korea
who prepares just the most exquisite
cuisine it is an art form to her and
there was a there was an amazing New
York Times profile about her it this is
in that tradition although the the
quality is probably not at her
exceptional level you know when we were
on the mountain we were immersed and
that definitely helped us in our own
mindset for shooting yeah amazing what a
gift I mean the first you're really the
first people to be able to go up there
and observe and document them in decades
it's shrouded in so much mystery I mean
I know there's that I've watched clips
from that grainy documentary and I know
I've seen the book
what's it called the marathon monks of
Mount Hiei but that's really it right in
terms of documenting this incredible
culture that's it you know that there's
a there's been a couple of short pieces
like to actually even be initiated into
the monastery people have to do a
hundred days times eleven miles
everybody does and they don't get the
whole uniform they don't get the big
bamboo hat and the staff they have to do
eleven miles a day for those hundred
days if they don't complete a single day
they don't have to kill themselves but
they don't get to be a part of the
monastery so there have been films about
that which look visually similar but
there haven't been people that have been
allowed up on the mountain while an
aspirant is in this thousand day quest
right you want to hear something that's
even wackier yeah I say wacky and the
most spiritual sense at the end of the
sixth cycle the aspirant has to do an
eight and a half day fast used to be a
ten day fast but too many aspirants died
during it used to be in the summer but
too many aspirants rotted from the
inside out because it's not just no food
it's no food no sleep the aspirant has
to sit up lotus position 24 hours a day
there are monks by him chanting with
them to keep him awake but the third
caveat and why it's so dangerous is no
water no food no water no sleep for
eight days eight and a half day how is
that possible I don't know I don't know
that traditionally the aspirants have
said that number one on the most human
level they can smell what you've eaten
the last three meals number two they can
smell any food that's being cooked on
the mountain number three and this is
where it's actually spiritual they're so
close to the verge of death that their
sensors are hyper attenuated they can
actually hear they say the ash falling
off of incense and so after you've
crossed that threshold or you've you
know straddle throughout that threshold
for a period of days and you come down I
don't think anything makes you afraid of
death anymore that is wild and and I
would imagine some the purpose of that
is to even heighten that level of
attainment
you know it's an it's an interesting
thing because the monks are doing
something exceptionally physical in this
quest and this you know that the mileage
is just mind-boggling but they're told
over and over and over that the mileage
is it important the main monk that spoke
to us refused to talk to us about the
mileage he refused to put anything you
know in any numbers on camera because he
said it's only about the prayers it's
only about the prayers but there's
recognition that the body is as vital to
this quest as the heart as the mind as
the soul as the center of prana the
father you know five major centers but
to hammer that point home you know after
you've had six and a half or you know
six years effectively of this deeply
spiritual physical practice I think they
want to kind of send you off on your
last four hundred days with a little bit
of a higher recognition that like
nothing can stop you if you made it past
that fast it doesn't matter you know
what comes your way
that is so wild it's crazy and there's
one last thing that have to do it gets
crazier they say this is harder although
it doesn't sound as hard at the end of
their tenth cycle they had to sit for
ten days for 12 to 14 hours a day in
front of a big bonfire and drop in
bamboo sticks that are that have priors
of individual devotees of the monastery
so they have like a million bamboo
sticks which they basically have to I
believe read and throw into the fire for
12 to 14 hours a day and the monk that
we spoke to who had done this if that
was more difficult for him because he
said that you need not allowed to drink
water during those 12 to 14 hours he
said he got more dehydrated every single
day and felt so felt closer to the end
every single day than he did through him
and towards the end of that eight and a
half day fast and once you complete this
then what they say you're a living
Buddha they say that you've you've now
crossed the threshold and your life is
only to be of service to aspirins so
the month that that was the previous
previous finisher who was our guide you
know all he does as he administers to
devotees you know 20 21 hours a day all
he's doing is serving his disciples and
it's exceptional because it's like
there's not a single minute in his day
that he doesn't use and it's really just
one person essentially every generation
more or less you know that I think that
every once in a while by the weird math
of years as a cross over where there's
two people that are doing it at the same
time but no one's ever really on the
course at the same time yeah that's
while what it what a gift to be able to
experience that and and I think another
thing that's interesting about that
quest as being you know very very
Buddhist and very Japanese that kind of
distinguishes it from a Hindu pursuit is
the idea that the body is essential
right a Hindu perspective would be more
along the lines of work trying to
transcend the body the body is just this
you know bag of bones that's here to
carry our consciousness but there isn't
attention to it in this very specific
way I mean in my own humble way India's
downfall in the last few hundred years
was disregarding the physical but if you
go back to the Bhagavad Gita the
physical is absolutely essential it's a
warrior text yeah the greatest spiritual
figures had understood the power of
their body you know they might have gone
to the forest like some of the great
sages and meditated for 10 15 20 years
at a time and practiced great
austerities but a lot of those
austerities came through physical
practice and nobody ever disregarded the
physical it was an essential part of our
spiritual being it's just been in the
last 300 400 500 years that there's kind
of been an infection in Hinduism this
idea that the body is Maya and that we
should disregard it and I think that's
led to a lot of ill in India including
being colonized we weren't strong enough
to like fight off this tiny little
eyelid for goodness doing enough yoga
it's like on it's like we're the land of
Krishna or the land of Arts and on when
these like pasty guys came off of boats
you know we surrendered yeah that's
crazy
well let's get back to the 3100 just
this is so fascinating this crazy race
and then and one of the things that
really struck me that's just undeniable
when you watch the movie is when you
take a gander at these 12 competitors
that show up to do this you may be
thinking these people are going to be
serious athletes are about to tackle
like the craziest thing you can possibly
imagine and then you look at them and
they just look like it's not that they
don't look it's not that they look uh
Natick but they don't strike you as
examples of the athlete you might be
imagining they just they're like
everyday people it's shocking
like and and to put it in the most kind
of like derogatory or discriminatory
language you know one of the best
runners is a plumber and it's like if
somebody told you he was a plumber you'd
go like yep I see it but if somebody
told you that like you know he can run
30 100 miles I'd agree but I'll say like
nope I can't see it little stocky
missing a few teeth 48 years old right
and you're right it's like people aren't
ripped they look like weekend warriors
they do you know and the true
protagonist of the movie is this guy
Oshkosh brother Josh praha all yeah
exactly oh no who is he's a paperboy
from Helsinki right
is he like 45 or something 44 years old
before but you know The Paperboy aspect
kind of belies this incredible focus on
a Spartan ask lifestyle he's chosen to
be a paperboy because he can train for
12 hours a day
you know he's pushing a little cart
through the streets of Helsinki going up
and down stairs delivering mail and for
him it's the ideal lifestyle like he's
he's on his feet 12 hours a day at the
same time he lives in a little tiny
cabin you know like a teenager he eats
ramen chocolate and soda all day long
and his sixth day mark
she's ten day mark is 833 miles which
means he run 83 miles a day for 10 days
he's ranked on all-time rankings of
these of races but it's like like you
said it's like the question is like how
does somebody who does not look like the
prototypical ultra runner achieve things
that the prototypically built ultra
runner probably couldn't even dream of
well it's because I don't really these
it's because all of these people are
first and foremost devotees and
secondarily runners not necessarily
devotees of sri Chinmoy but they're
they're devotees of on this path towards
higher consciousness and the athletic
aspect is really just a vehicle for that
that that's exactly right there there
was a gentleman from Germany named
Wolfgang work who has the second best 24
hour race time of all time I believe
around a hundred and eighty miles done
in 24 hours and he came to do the race
in 2004 and averaged 76 miles a day and
he looked like an ultra runner world
champion in a number of different races
tall lean athletically built but for a
German he had actually taken up the name
mud lupron an Indian name and he was
following another Eastern spiritual
teacher so he had an attitude that was
beyond competition even though he was a
globally ranked ultra distance runner
mm-hmm
have you thought about what you think
might happen if suddenly you know Rob
car like the the current crop of like
elite ultra endurance runner showed up
to tackle this race what might happen
well you know we did a pre-screening of
3,100 runner to come in Denver and Clara
Gallagher was there and Chrissie mol and
Mike Wardian had just finished I
believed the Hard Rock and he lives on
the East Coast and
kids had wanted to see ant-man and so he
goes into this random theater in Denver
what we're doing this pre-screening and
he sees Chrissy and Claire and he goes
like what are you doing here they're
like aren't you here for the running
movie he's like no I'm here to see
ant-man and they're like come see the
running movie he's like absolutely
pushed his kids into ant-man and after
the movie he said you know we all have
known that this race existed but it's
not on social media you know there's no
real way to learn about it you know it's
like when people climbed Everest there
isn't like documentation in the New York
Times once a decade the New York Times
writes a story on the 3100
but that's it and he said afterwards
I've always been curious about this race
and now I'm a lot more curious and you
know he's vegan he meditates and I think
he also was once kind of sponsored by
Carnival Cruise Lines to run some crazy
distance around the deck of a ship so
you know he's got everything you need
he's got the inner attitude he's also
got this like mindset where you can run
in a circle for countless hours and you
can see the movie sparks something in
him Camille Heron who I think has a
fifty-mile world record for females won
the comrades marathon she emailed me
that she's always been interested in the
self-transcendence race I think there's
so much mystery around it and I'm hoping
that the film will unlock some of that
mystery and show that's like a ship
Rehan all he doesn't care about
nutrition he doesn't care about anything
other than the meditative aspects of the
race other people are much more
regimented but they all like you said
had that same type of inner attitude
where they're expecting to become better
people through this race and that hope
and belief and reality is what helps
them make it through the miles yeah I
mean he repeats time and time again that
this is his meditation that's why he's
doing it right and then the race each
day starts with a one-minute meditation
and he you know you could see his head
is bowed and his eyes are closed and and
he kind of begins that run with his sort
of offhanded shuffle that he does you
know it's like you see him going and
you're like look at that form how is
that guy possibly gonna run 30 100 miles
you know do you
previous question I think people like
Rob Timothy Olsen tamasam yeah you know
people like that Clara Gallagher there's
a whole crop of people that have popped
up scott jurek i'm obviously you know
incredible runner who've done these like
epic races but this like like
otherworldly focus you know if they use
that determination and also they
probably have it but built the patience
understanding that this is a 52 day race
or 45 day race if you're going really
fast I think they'd have exceptional
experiences you know and then do
exceptionally well you know our Navajo
character Sean Martin's dad Alan Martin
who's in the movie as a medicine man and
the Navajo hadn't ever allowed people to
film the running prayers and for some
reason he wanted to open it up to us and
got permission from other elders and so
he was asking me who were the keepers of
the land of the 3100 and yeah he's a
very normal very deep and beautiful man
and I'm not trying to make this sound
like he's some like mean like shaman up
in the hills but he said like who are
the keepers at the land of the 3100 and
I'm thinking like this is a sidewalk
around Thomas Edison High School
bordering the Grand Central in Queens
and so I said well the Lenni Lenape
tribe used to be there but they left in
the 1600 1700s and he said they've kept
this land sacred and I said does that
mean that they they knew that the 3100
was gonna be there he said of course not
but it's like any time and this is what
he said he said any time there is a
sacred race held on a particular piece
of land that piece of land was destined
for that race for the Navajo and a lot
of Native Americans it's like places
have consciousness to a greater degree
than than they do for you know any of us
in the West it's not just the beautiful
mountains that have consciousness or
that deserve prayer and worship it's
everything it's the rock faces it's the
rock walls it's the pathways it's the
plants it's it's the the consciousness
of the dirt you know and so he basically
said that this course has been
consecrated for time immemorial
even though it's crazy to think that
like sidewalks have consciousness you
can either say that runners have
attributed the consciousness to it or
they've drawn drawn out the
consciousness that course has this
exceptionally deep peace for the
location that it's in right it's so
ironic and bizarre though because you
just it it defies any notion of what you
think that course should look like and
back to Coby Oren it's like here's a guy
who's so set on competition and so good
at it and you know so expectant of being
able to set records that he even
realized that the race is dictated by
the course and the course dictates that
you look at this as a pilgrimage and a
lot of people have done the
Transcontinental like from San Cisco to
New York and the logistics of going up
the Sierras the Wasatch the Rockies and
then the flats in the rolling hills of
Nebraska are exceptionally challenging
and it's very difficult from seeing
people who've done that race you know to
disassociate your mind from the trucks
whizzing by you know the lack of aid
every half a mile but this course allows
the type of flow yeah it's almost you
know the simplicity of it the fact that
it is so banal contributes to the
ultimate goal which is to kind of you
know transcend physical place and and
and and reach some kind of higher state
of consciousness and the repetitiveness
of it it's almost like repeating a
mantra you know or using a you know a
mala or a prayer be it's a it's a it's
ritualized in its own way the repetitive
nature the fact that it's only a
half-mile and not a two-mile course the
fact that you're constantly passing the
same thing there's something about that
that almost creates that trance-like
State or allows that to you know
percolate to the surface perhaps with a
little bit more facility I mean there's
two outcomes for discipline right
there's there's austerity which is
suffering but with a lot of
determination and there's joy I'm sure
people have had the experience of
austerity in that race in fact I know
from mantras that you know oftentimes
the first six to ten days are filled
with exceptional suffering where the
body the mind the heart are getting used
to the pounding to the repetitiveness to
the monotony but at some point in that
race like for Sean Martin when he leaves
his door in the Navajo Nation his
discipline is translating to join in the
3,100 those of us with the Western
mindset find that or see that it takes
six to ten days for the runners to
overcome suffering and channel that
focus and that discipline into joy but
even the craziest most sociopathic
psychotic loony insane person on earth
could not complete 30 100 miles so the
question is like why are they doing it
it's not because they're crazy it's not
considered like a padlet as a path of
austerity or suffering compounding into
more suffering it's because there's a
legitimate feeling of joy and there I
say bliss that these runners feel and
you end up seeing it in their faces if
someone wants to go there you know the
race is usually from mid-june to August
yeah it's it's not like there's a big
crowd of people there you could design
walk right up and be right there and all
the runners will come up and greet you
they want to talk to you they don't want
to they want to offer their joy not just
because they're lonely out to here but
because it's like they're feeling these
like deep deep emotions and feelings and
it's it's like the Japanese say it's
like when you're feeling that it's like
you want to be an emissary between in
the Japanese sense the Buddha and
humanity or here between your soul and
humanity you're feeling something that
you feel that other people are looking
for and you can offer it and so these
runners they're like little vessels
going around in a circle how come it
doesn't get more attention you'd think
like okay here it goes again it's been
going on forever you're in New York City
you know media capital of the planet why
aren't why aren't people writing about
this and
talking about it more you know and this
is why I wanted to do this movie ESPN
and a few other filmmakers that tried to
do a movie on the 3100 and the only way
to approach it I found is through the
spirituality and if you're looking at
making a movie something has to be
inherently visual that 30-100 isn't
visual but that's why we have the
Kalahari Bushmen the Japanese monks the
Navajo people that have come to write
about 3100 have either just focused on
the mind-numbing that like like foot
splitting realities of the mileage and
is only so often that you can write
about that but the deepest articles have
been about the spirituality and that
really relies on the writers that relies
on the editors to recognize that this
isn't a one-day assignment and we were
out there for 52 days this is a
fifty-two day assignment because drama
happens in moments and you have to be
there when someone has kind of like a
flowering of a spiritual experience does
it make you want to do it it does you
know filmmaking is really a really hard
lifestyle for me because we're always
traveling and you know I've been told
that my body type is like of a bird
meeting and and the practitioner told me
this was like what does a bird need and
I said worms he said no a bird need the
nest so it's like you aren't meant to be
traveling but I'm always traveling so I
still do 45 or 50 miles a week but the
train for this race apparently the way
to do it is you know five or six mile
runs Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday 45 or 50 Sunday 35 or 40
that's what everyone says that's the way
to go it's like stacking it's like you
want time on your feet and even then
it's like you don't need to worry about
pace like I did it was one of the best
training runs of my life I did a run
with more than 30 100 mile run errs or
we started in Queens
I had my my MasterCard we ran eight
miles to a donut shop because you have
to train and eat yeah we ate Donuts
that's the thing about running in New
York there's always someplace to go I
know Chuck didn't eat you're never too
far away and so we ended up doing a
30-mile training run that was just going
from like smoothie bar to Ron
shop and that's the way they train you
know they run 4050 miles on my Ted
Corbett on one day and they try to
repeat that to get their body used to
the idea of like maximum mileage was
your arrest
well entrepreneur all he sort of said he
doesn't really he didn't even really
train right he just lives an active
lifestyle where he's kind of moving all
the time and he didn't really put too
much thought into some kind of race
specific program so I I asked him and
again he'd done the race thirteen times
before and he's gone how many times
eight times eight times right so I asked
him like what's the most important thing
and I think every ultra runner knows
this in their heart your ability to
finish a race is directly proportional
to your ability to overcome problems and
to realize that most problems aren't
actual problems and so Ashby Hinault
tries to change activities every chance
he gets to during the daytime to keep
his mind nimble and to realize that it's
like you can have a problem and you can
push past that problem by changing the
way you approach it changing your
activity changing your mindset this
parts not in the film but we ended up
going with OSH Brunel to Japan where he
was climbing Mount Fuji as a way to
train for the 3,100 that's amazing it's
so counterintuitive because you would
think the best way to train for this is
to run as much as possible and to really
connect with what it feels like to stay
in it in that same repetitive motion for
as long as possible irrespective of the
level of discomfort that you're
experiencing and that would mean just
doing the same thing as long as possible
I think there's two reasons why he tried
to climb Fuji number one he wanted to do
it in the winter with no preparation so
by the time it got up the mountain his
feet his shins were covered with
blisters and he knew he couldn't he
would never have worse blisters than he
did on that trip and the physical
challenge was so enormous again he knew
that he'd never faced anything like that
in the 3,100 at the same time like when
you are going around the block you are
relying on your power to visualize and
being in those exceptionally beautiful
areas gave him the imagination you know
to be able to like just transport
mind off right well there was that other
guy who had horrible blisters Vasu Vasu
had a booster horrific yeah we honestly
the size of like a lemon yeah you know I
never see blisters like that in my life
and he did 700-mile kept going with
those that with that like I can't
believe he didn't quit Vasu is also like
the sweetest most sincere person on that
course we're like he's just overflowing
with gratitude I mean like that's the
combination of spirituality right trying
to be grateful to everything and you see
him he's just like just this like mush
ball of gratitude and he's pounding out
70 to 75 miles a day and you'd expect to
see these athletes throw temper tantrums
once in a while with their crew and you
don't see any of that you know as people
will see in the movie one of the r8 and
one of the first time participants a
woman named Xiaomi two Achenbach Koenig
who's a professional cellist you know
thousand mile ten-day specialist she
decided to bring her husband as her
handler and for people who've done you
know stage racers or 50 miles 100 100
miles with crew I think they had all
agreed that like your worst handler as
your spouse yeah that's what they say so
he was her handler and you can't lose
them like if you're on a hundred mile er
and you lose them for 10 20 miles and
then you see them again you know every
half a mile he was there with you know
pure love but also pure concern hmm for
her he kept telling her like you got to
drop out you know and people will see
this in the movie but in 1996 she did an
ultra in Vienna a hundred K race where
you know she was hot it was 80 85
degrees she overheated and she was in a
coma for two days and the 30 180 day 80
degree day is cool you know a couple
summers ago even this summer it was 95
98 degrees for 6 8 days in a row and
that's not even heat index s just like
air temperature and how many people
dropped out last year there was there's
a very few Americans have done this race
there's been one woman named super Bob
Becker from DC who did
13 years in a row and finished it the
first finisher was a man named Kelly
there was another American man that did
it to last summer an african-american
woman 60 years old named Yolanda holder
finished with 15 minutes to spare and
she was a race Walker so there's only a
certain pace that you can keep up so she
had a couple bad days and she couldn't
make it up by doing a 70 75 mile day she
had to do like one lap extra you know
every day she came back as 61 to do it
this summer but unlike most summers the
first two weeks of this year's race the
temperatures were already hot yeah and
she had blisters the size of aa CIO's
like the size of like half lemons after
12 days ulcers in fact and nobody's
young no well the youngest finisher was
29 really was that recent or that was
about 10 years ago yeah I mean they all
look like they're in their 50s and 60s
and I think that speaks to the kind of
spiritual strength that you need it's
not brute physicality because unless you
can tap into a deeper energy you're not
gonna get joy out of it yeah let's talk
about the Navajo a little bit I I didn't
realize that there was this rich running
culture that you know infused the Navajo
Nation Native Americans didn't have any
other modes of transportation other than
their feet until the Spanish brought
horses and even even then even though
the Spanish came in the 1500s it wasn't
until you know really the late 1500s in
some parts the late 1600s that Native
Americans indigenous people had access
to horses what they did for thousands of
years as they ran they were exceptional
runners there's a story of a man named
Louis
Tawana me who was into anima who was a
Hopi runner and represented the Olympic
the USA in the Olympics in 1912 and he
went back to the Hopi nation to do an
exhibition 10k race and he and another
kind of anglicized westernized
there's other reasons why they were
anglicized they appeared in their
singlets and a couple of elders said you
know you're gonna dress like that to do
a race up here on the Mesa and this was
a person who
actually third place in the Olympics
lowest wanama and the elder said I'll
beat you and apparently the two elders
who were right who jumped in the race
were so far ahead of the two kind of
modern participants after three or four
miles that one of them the the bronze
medalist in the 1912 Olympics dropped
out that's a true running wasn't just a
way of life running was a way to connect
with Mother Earth and with father sky it
gave men and women you know such a deep
sense of place in a deep sense of power
in a lot of southwestern traditions the
Navajo in particular running is still
used as a coming-of-age ceremony the
equivalent of a bat mitzvah is practiced
and young girls as one of the last rites
of passage have to go on long runs it
wasn't just exercise it's like if you
look at one of the most spiritual
practices the coming-of-age ceremonies
and realize that like long-distance
running is a part of that you can get a
glimpse into how important it was that's
amazing
what do you I mean this is a little bit
of scans but how do you think about that
relationship between running and it
being this this this really primal
transcendent experience like why running
why not something else like what is it
about running that triggers that in the
human body and mind you know when we
were with the Kalahari Bushmen and they
had been living in an unbroken lineage
in the Kalahari Desert in Botswana and
northern South Africa for more than
125,000 years and evolutionary
biologists say that we might not have
all descended only from the San Bushmen
of the Kalahari but each one of us has
DNA markers that are only found or only
exhibited by the San Bushmen so it's
like we flowed through those people when
we were with them I asked them I said
like you know and they they they run to
survive they go on long persistence
hunts
and what that means is that you know
when we were beasts on the Savannah we
didn't have a physical advantage over
any of the creatures from the large elk
to obviously the the big you know the
big cats what we could do was run for
quite long distances we'd sweat through
every pore of our body at the same time
you know when we took steps those steps
were decoupled from our breathing
apparatus a horse or a dog when they
extend fully their forelegs
that rib cage expands take a breath when
they push off all four legs come
together and the breath is pushed out
there are anaerobic you know machines
we're aerobic machines at the same time
we learned how to carry water we could
carry water in gourds or in skins and we
learned to chase big beasts away from
watering holes and they'd run 3040 miles
you know in a in a gallop and we'd track
them and we'd scare them away from the
watering holes that we knew were in that
area until after two or three days they
were quivering masses and like
dehydrated flesh and it was easy to
approach them with a poison arrow and
and shoot them so that's how we survived
on the Savannah at the same time there's
a deep cosmology among the San Bushmen
around running and the practice of
hunting they say when they run and hunt
they're able to access the power of
their ancestors they're able to access
the power of the earth to overcome the
the feebleness and the weaknesses of the
human body and so my question posed to
one of their one of their hunters was
you know what came first did you build a
I mean not that he would he's an
anthropologist but do you know was was
there was the cosmology around running
built because of the physical reality
that running was our weapon right that
necessity drove it and he said no he
said that we hunted because we
understood the power of running like
running was our spiritual practice and
we challenged that we channeled that
into an ability to survive running was
the first religion one would also say
but running and motion motion on mother
earth and using the human body that
channel non human are superhuman
energies that was man and a woman's
first religion that's baked into us as
mammals mm-hmm
that's amazing you know I I'm not sure I
totally got that from the movie because
when you when we explore the Kalahari
it's it's more about the threat to their
way of life because of hunting bands and
and how they're kind of trying to figure
out how to preserve this culture of
running and their way of life in the
wake of you know changes in the modern
world that have now basically told them
they can't do what they've always done
but I didn't I didn't understand the
spiritual depth of how deeply that runs
you know there was a in in this type of
a movie where we're trying to combine
the 3100 the color it's trying to show
all these different stories and trying
to make them all work together there
were only certain ways that they would
all work together you know and some
things had to be left on there of course
cutting room floor nature of it at the
same time it's like as you saw in the
movie when you see people still running
after animals it forces us to pose that
question where we try to dive into the
cosmology into the spiritual power that
running might be you're able to afford
somebody and that's kind of the impetus
of the movie yeah I mean what I got out
of that is you know just for people that
are listening a ban has been placed on
hunting and the kalahari are in this
position of saying okay do we defy the
ban or do we adhere to the law and
ultimately a great peril of themselves
they say we're gonna do it anyway and
you can look at that a number of
different ways you can say well they're
just they're not law-abiding citizens or
you can say frankly maybe they don't
have a choice this is so deeply bred
into who they are that they just have to
do it no matter what
in 1997 the I'm using the color because
it's important in this case the black
Botswana in government found copper
underneath the Kalahari Desert which is
the size of Massachusetts and it was
considered an uninhabitable mass and the
Kalahari Bushmen were allowed to to live
there unmolested even though they'd only
been discovered less than a hundred
years before but once copper and other
resources were found this anti
indigenous colonial mindset kicked in
and the entire population of the San
Bushmen were relocated much like almost
every single native population in the
United States North America was
relocated so we actually took one of our
associate producers who's the executive
director of wings of America the native
running organization with us on that
trip and his face was even so he's a
dark-skinned fellow but his face was
ashen white most the time because he
recognized that what happened to his
ancestors on the Navajo Nation in 1868
you know when four years prior that they
were forced marched off their nation
because a civil war general thought that
there was gold there that could finance
the entire Civil War proved to be untrue
he was seeing that happen to the
Kalahari he was seeing an entire
generation that was forcibly separated
from the culture and our main hunting
character was forced off the Kalahari
and like you said for the movie chose to
sneak back onto their ancestral home
site penalty of death and penalty of
imprisonment if he was caught hunting
but the hunting ban was placed as an
excuse saying that the the San Bushmen
you know shouldn't be allowed to hunt
animals because we have a lot of
tourists coming in to look at animals
and we don't want them to kill them the
San Bushmen said no animal species have
been you know extinct in the or you know
wiped out by us in the last hundred
twenty-five thousand years so there's a
complex set of rationale it's
complicated but the main thing is that
the government is forcibly trying to
strip these ancient runners of their
ability to run and hunt yeah and that
dovetails into Shawn's story on the
Navajo Nation this this hundred mile run
that he embarks upon that you Chronicle
is really his way of connecting with his
ancestry by traveling from the school
that his father
there was correct me if I'm wrong the
school that his father was the sort of
Governments quality with his father was
forced to attend that taught you know
the traditional historical record that
is at odds with this person you know
this tribes experience traveling all the
way to the his father's ancestral
homeland accurate its absolutely
accurate it was legal in the United
States to forcibly remove a Native
American boy or girl from his or her
parents until 1977 and what that really
led from was this notion that by
stripping Indian kids away from their
cultures they could the phrase was kill
the Indian save the man if you killed
the cultural part of the Indian you
would save his or her soul
indoctrinating them into a historical
record that basically you know tells the
conventional wisdom of America and
friend and forbidding them from speaking
their own language and forbidding them
from their ancient practices so our
Navajo character Sean Martin his dad
Alan was forcibly removed from their
property in northwestern Arizona to a
government boarding school near
Flagstaff and as a six year old boy he
was so traumatized that annually he
began sneaking out of the school and
running at night a hundred and ten miles
back home a number of kids tried that
the father did or Shonda the father did
a number of kids around the country that
were that were forcibly schooled tried
that and many many died and this was a
trauma that young Shawn Shawn Martin the
the modern-day Runner lived with he knew
that his father had a terrible childhood
at the same time he knew that running
saved his father he and his brothers
became exceptional runners but they ran
to the point of absolute physical
suffering because they knew of the
suffering that their dad experienced was
a way to connect with that yeah so in
the film we look at four aspects we look
at running to transcend like the 3100
mile race running to survive
like the Kalahari Bushmen running for
enlightenment like the monks and then
running to heel you know either your own
trauma or this historical trauma of your
people and Sean's run from loop outside
of Flagstaff up to his ancestral home
site was about a hundred and ten miles
and I don't know if I've seen anybody
who was shouldering so much
responsibility
Sean's a teacher and then a very popular
person on the on the Navajo Nation and a
lot of people knew that he was running
in honor of his father and because they
all had relatives that had been forcibly
schooled they all felt that he was
running for their relatives so Sean
carried not just his own historical
trauma on this run but the expectations
and the trauma of hundreds of other
people yeah I didn't realize that that's
a that's a heavy burden to bear it was
heavy it's hard enough as people know
like running an ultra but when you're
running an ultra to challenge pain and
we're overcoming that pain means success
and if you don't overcome that pain the
Run was for naught and so that's what he
was doing he was trying to use this run
as almost like a last-ditch effort to
address the trauma of his dad's
childhood and Sean's son who lives a
very wonderful and I would say sheltered
life on the Navajo Reservation compared
to this young boy's grandfather Sean's
father was accompanying Sean in the car
and Sean's dad was too and so it was
just a beautiful experience to watch
this family not just come to terms not
just heal their trauma but expose it and
address it for a lot of people that
couldn't run the same way that Sean was
running and a lot of people whose
ancestors died unlike Sean's dad hmm
yeah he's running across the most
beautiful landscape I mean there's no
eight stations here he's not running on
highways or Road it's like he is in the
middle of nowhere and the most beautiful
landscape you can imagine
and I think anyone who has been to
Monument Valley which is on the Navajo
Nation or to other kind of exceptionally
beautiful landmarks in Indian country
realize that when Native Americans say
that mother earth is the equivalent of
the divine you see it you know it's like
if the Grand Canyon isn't like something
that that transports your mind and heart
into other planes of consciousness you
know nothing ever will yeah
what has the process of making this
movie taught you or how has it changed
you I guess with respect of running of
course but also in terms of how you
think about an approach your life at one
point I fancied myself as a quasi
competitive runner I mean even in high
school in a state the state of
California with 30 million people I was
you know one of the top right middle
distance runners burned out by mid
college really didn't know why I was
running in my 20s I was still racing a
little bit marathons and stuff 30s also
didn't really have a purpose for running
it wasn't until I met Sean and Sean said
again that running is a prayer for the
Navajo it's a celebration of life it's
not punishment it's a teacher it's like
if you're going through hardships you
know don't just sleep on it you know
don't go eat like a tub of ice cream or
a bar of chocolate address it and
address it the way humanity used to
address it by connecting to your breath
and to your feet mm-hmm that totally
changed my attitude towards running at
the same time you know again I I'm I'm I
guess these days I'm a person of color
but I reject those types of labels and I
think running is a safe way to show that
there are actually things that unites
people like you know when you're on a
trailer or you're in a race there's no
red there's no blue there's no elections
you're not you when you're running
especially when you're competing you
only have yourself and if you're in a
relay your teammates but ultimately you
have your feet and your
and your heart it's elemental and that's
given me a lot of solace it's like I
know that we've been running for
millions of years and it's an activity
that we're gonna continue doing for
hundreds of thousands more regardless of
what the political state of humanity is
we can go back to that state I think
we'll all realize that there are things
that unite us that are much stronger
than the things that we think divide us
yeah this this ritualization of human
behavior and I like the characterization
of running as a vehicle to connect with
your breath and the power of breath
right when you think of it in those
terms it starts to sound a lot more like
a meditation practice than an athletic
endeavor at the same time I think the
question is here's a question for you
like how do you balance your spiritual
life and the aspect of competitive
racing yeah that's a tricky thing right
I mean I think my personal perspective
on competition has always been in Word
facing like I'm not that concerned with
what anyone else is doing I'm trying to
be the best version of myself and if I
can walk away from an event satisfied
that I had that I had done that then
that's a win irrespective of whatever
the leaderboard says right and I think
that's echoed in the movie with these
runners in the 3100 as much as you know
opera opera ha nul
I don't know how to say that that's
exactly right is I don't want to spoil
it
I was about to I was about to spoil that
but I'm not going to
he he he sort of iterates throughout the
movie that it's not a it's not it is a
competition but that it's really not
about that and I think the more these
competitors or anybody for that matter
can can get to a place of being able to
let go of that externality ultimately
the better they perform anyway we began
our theatrical run on Friday in Santa Fe
and as you know the film is going to be
rolling out around the country from the
southwest to the Pacific Northwest
California Colorado but we were really
lucky that an opening night Billy Mills
the Oglala Lakota 10
meter champion from the 1964 Olympics
was our was the host of the advance goal
and I got to ask him that very same
question I said from a traditional
native standpoint you've told us about
the importance of the spirituality of
running at the same time it's like you
made your mark as a competitive runner
winning a race that nobody but you
thought you were gonna win I mean nobody
thought that Billy Rose was going to win
that ten thousand meter race and if
anybody needs a pick-me-up just on
YouTube
type in Billy Mills Olympics greatest
last lap I think in any modern race and
he said exactly what you did he said I
never raced to compete he said even when
I won I was racing against myself I was
in racing against my pain I was racing
against my limitation I was racing
against what my body was telling me it
couldn't do and I pushed it beyond and
just so happened that I won the 1964
Olympic gold medal in the 10,000 meters
but like that's not how I defined my
races yeah that was the external
manifestation of of a mindset that
allowed him to do that but it wasn't
that goal no and that's the interesting
thing because I think like once I
realized that I could run for spiritual
reasons that became a better competitor
you know it's like I was much less
dissatisfied with the second or third
even in a local race than I ever would
have been it's like I look a lot more -
preparation I look a lot more - the
ritual of practice and I know that if I
show up with the starting line and I've
done all the right things I'm gonna have
a good experience you sound like you're
ready to toe the line at next year's
3100 I would love to yeah I love lock
day if not next year than the year after
have have you shown to the Moot shown
the movie to any of the protagonists yet
I did we did a little screening for the
stars of the movie
you came out yeah how are you know we
haven't generated them yet we gotta show
it well they probably don't have Wi-Fi
up there you can't send them a link
III wanna I want to be there and watch
someone they see it but we showed it to
a lot of our Navajo characters in Sedona
at a film festival which was our
official world premiere in June and
we decided to start our theatrical
launch not in New York or LA where
everybody wanted us to our distributor
in particular because it's such a
Southwestern story and it's like we
wanted to bring it to the southwestern
native populations so we launched in
Santa Fe then Albuquerque and then
Phoenix and Sedona and then go up to the
mountain cities like and I'd say
Mountain like outdoor cities like
Portland and Seattle and Boulder and
Denver before hitting all the big ones
yeah that's that's great that's that's
very smart
guerilla marketing as well did you know
to hit the hot beds of running where
people are gonna be really interested in
this and and create that kind of good
word of mouth at our premiere in Santa
Fe Henry Roanoke came Henry was one of
the first Kenyans to come to the United
States for schooling in the 70s around
Philly I think University of Washington
went to Washington State but in 1978 he
set for World Records from the the 3,000
meters to the 10,000 meters
I think even including the the the 3,000
meter steeplechase in the matter of just
a few months and this is like in the 70s
and so Henry told me he said when I grew
up in Kenya it's like I never practiced
running we hunted in the 60s like this
isn't like ancient history like the
ancient Bushmen he said in the 60s yeah
we all hunted and that's how I ran I
would run 20 30 miles 40 miles for play
you know and for work and that's how we
trained it's like we didn't separate
this is the interesting thing for me we
didn't separate running from our way of
life we didn't put on new gear to go
running we didn't take off our old gear
to go inside he said everything was done
in the same stuff because it was all a
part of our life yeah you still see that
I think with some of the cultures in
Ethiopia and Kenya with you know these
great marathon runners Kip choked and
and the rest oh yeah it really emanates
from from a way of life this summer Jim
Wamsley who won the the western states
you know he trained up at altitude and
lived basically in a tent the last six
weeks and
preparation for the UTMB and you look at
that and you go like that seems so
elemental the idea of just living to run
and running to live yeah all right we
got to wrap this up but I think we can
close it down with a final question
which is what is it that you want people
to take away from this movie that's a
great question I think a lot of people
have come in contact with running some
people haven't enjoyed it because they
weren't taught the real purpose of
running think a lot of us that do enjoy
running might not have the words to
expand our enjoyment of running and I'm
not saying that I know anything more
than anybody else but the characters in
the 3100 bring these perspectives which
I hesitate to say aren't mainstream but
they're so core and identifiable that
I'm hoping that when people see the
movie they'll have a newfound
appreciation not just for running but
for physical activity and our place in
the world yeah I would imagine you come
across people who will say this is great
but like I hate running yeah right yeah
it's like if you hate running that's
okay but it's like do you like walking
do you like hawk hiking is there a way
is there an activity where you can go
outside and put your feet on Mother
Earth and understand that your breath is
your connection to the heavens do that
like that's the attitude that we all
used to have back before we were
encumbered by cars and shoes and Strava
and GPS and all so when you see the
runners in in the 3100 and you see what
they're actually doing it might change
how you define running for yourself it's
definitely a lot not what you think no
and it's a lot harder for me to like cop
out of doing a daily workout now that I
know that you know on any of my weekdays
of three five six seven miles somebody
out there could have been doing 50 or 60
miles yeah yeah
well awesome I love the movie 31 run and
become very emotionally impacted by you
did a beautiful job it's a it's it's
really just a fascinating exploration of
this relationship this nexus between
running and spirituality and
self-improvement and how this really is
part of what makes us human and thank
you for making the movie I'm really
grateful for the chance to have shown
you the movie you obviously an
inspiration to me into a lot of people
and I hope that you know we can all just
follow in the footsteps of your work and
the other great guests that you have on
No thank you
if people want to see the movie where
should they go to find the schedule they
can go to WWE 1 0-0 3100 film.com we're
playing all over the country four to
five shows a day rolling out city by
city yeah excellent man awesome and I'm
gonna see you later this week right
you're coming to the running for good
screening super exciting very good man
we're gonna do a live podcast it's the
premiere of that movie super excited to
have you thank you for sharing today
thanks so much right is there anywhere
else where people can connect with you
there's an Instagram account for the
movie at three one zero zero film mom at
3100 film and then on Facebook
facebook.com forward slash 3100 film you
can message that and I'm the one
answering mother message or the guy the
guy hit me up let me know if you're
coming out your screening and yeah well
I'll say hi all right cool we did it
thank you
you've how do you feel I feel great this
is one of the most inspiring
conversations I've had like a year and a
half good well come back again we'll do
it again thank you all right thanks
Sanjay peace plants running
[Music]